vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le
partenariat rénové entre l'union
européenne et l'union africaine
150 milliards d'euros d'investissements
et une aide pour cause de leurs et
vaccins anti covit sur le continent
africain ce sont les grandes lignes du
sixième sommet europe afrique qui s'est
clôturé ce vendredi à bruxelles nous y
retrouverons notre corps est purement
rfi pour france 24 pierre bénazet afin
d'évoquer aussi le volet sécuritaire
avec les retraits des forces françaises
du mali et leurs conséquences dans la
région pour les forces européennes
et parmi les décisions du sommet il y à
l'aide de 425 millions pour accélérer
les campagnes de vaccination soutenant
la distribution de doses et un transfert
de technologie afin d'aider les pays
africains à fabriquer les vaccins à arn
messagers sur place les explications à
suivre dans ce journal
[Musique]
et c'est l'événement trois mois après le
retour au bénin des 26 oeuvres du trésor
dabo mais la population vont enfin
pouvoir admirer dans une exposition
exceptionnelle au palais de la marina
dès ce week-end pour l'occasion on y
retrouvera meriam amellal en direct
depuis cotonou pour une grande page
spéciale restez avec nous
on ouvre ce journal par les ambitions de
l'union européenne et de l'union
africaine pour un partenariat rénové
face aux crises internationales les deux
continents réunis à bruxelles ont décidé
de réinventer la relation 150 milliards
d'euros d'investissements ont été
annoncés l'objectif affiché est de
contrer les influences russes et
chinoises de plus en plus grande et
parmi les décisions prises lors de ce
sixième sommet il y a le volet
sécuritaire pour en parler on retrouve à
bruxelles pierre bénazet le
correspondant rfi pour france 24 pierre
ce jeudi matin le président français a
annoncé le retrait du mali des forces
françaises barkan mais aussi celles
européennes de takouba mais quelle est
la peau six positions des partenaires de
lieux sur le volet sécuritaire en
afrique alors en fait pour les européens
l'aspect de participation aux opérations
militaires est redevenu relativement
intenable on sait que au sahel la france
a été en pointe pour les pays de l'union
européenne puisque ce sont les premières
interventions et c'était les plus gros
contingents il ya aussi on le sait un
peu c'est connu en afrique les forces
prépositionnées que ce soit en afrique
de l'ouest ou ailleurs en afrique donc
pour les européens la france était le
partenaire était à la fois le soutien et
le support il y avait le soutien
logistique et le support aérien ça
c'était des choses indispensables pour
ces pays européens que la france avait
réussi à convaincre de s'engager dans
cette force takouba on a vu que pour le
danemark ça a été un peu un coup dans
l'eau en quelque sorte puisque dès le
départ le danemark récemment le danemark
a dû renoncer à sa participation et
commencer à rapatrier ses hommes la
norvège se poser des questions
l'allemagne aussi se pose des questions
sur sa participation à la péniche pas
et puis pour les européens la grosse
question maintenant est de savoir s'ils
vont réussir à maintenir leurs
engagements des missions de formation
des forces armées celles de utm il y à
celle au mali qui est évidemment menacé
par le départ de dagoba et puis il y à
aussi celles en centrafrique qui est
menacée pour le coup par la présence des
mercenaires russes
delà du groupe wagner ce qui pose le
principal problème à long terme pour
l'union européenne c'est effectivement
cette présence des mercenaires russes et
donc les européens maintenant vont
devoir trouver des solutions les
ministres des affaires étrangères se
réunissent à nouveau la semaine
prochaine à bruxelles et ils vont devoir
prendre des décisions
merci pierre bénazet depuis bruxelles
merci beaucoup
parmi les autres décisions prises lors
de ce sixième sommet entre l'union
européenne et l'union africaine il y a
les vaccins 425 millions d'euros
financés par l'union l'union européenne
pour accélérer les campagnes de
vaccination en soutenant la distribution
des doses et la formation des équipes
médicales mais le point d'orgue et
l'aide apportée pour produire les
vaccins arn messagers pour produire sur
place les vaccins à est un messager pour
lutter contre le comique le renverser
cher
c'est l'une des grandes annonces de ce
sommet europe afrique six pays africains
vont bientôt commencer à produire leur
propre vaccin à arn message est une
avancée pour l'égalité vaccinale saluée
par la présidente de la commission
aujourd'hui seuls 1% des vaccins
administrés en afrique sont produits sur
le continent
le but est d'atteindre les 60 % d'ici
chaperonné par l' oms ce projet ouvre la
voie au transfert encadrer des
technologies arn mais il ne prévoit pas
la levée complète des brevets demandé
par de nombreux pays africains les
dirigeants européens ont réitéré leur
opposition à cette idée qu'ils jugent
nuisible à l'innovation et la propriété
intellectuelle
mais pour cyril ramaphosa seule une
levée complète des brevets pourrait
permettre à l'afrique d'être
autosuffisante en matière de production
de vaccins
il n'est pas acceptable que l'afrique
soit constamment à la fin de la file
d'attenté lorsqu'il s'agit de l'accès
aux soins médicaux
même si nous sommes reconnaissants pour
les dons il ne représente pas une
manière ou un mécanisme qui permet de
construire de la résidence au delà du
transfert de technologie l'union
européenne s'est également engagé à
fournir 450 millions de doses aux pays
africains d'ici le début de l'été et à
investir plus de 400 millions d'euros
pour soutenir les campagnes de
vaccination
il ya trois mois la france organiser de
façon formelle la restitution au bénin
de 26 oeuvres des trésors du royaume
d'abomey près de 130 ans après leur
pillage par le général d'ahold les
oeuvres vont enfin pouvoir est admiré
par les populations mais ce retour n'a
pas été un long fleuve tranquille
bien au contraire au tour sur ce
feuilleton politique avec emmanuel sodji
le 17 novembre 1892 après plusieurs
semaines de violents combats le colonel
dote à la tête d'une armée assiège le
royaume de béhanzin l'un des plus
farouches résistant à la colonisation
française en guise de butin de guerre un
patrimoine historique et pillé notamment
des trolls géants en bois sculpté des
portes sacré les statuts du duroux est
celle des rois de glèlè et de béhanzin
l'actuel président du bénin patrice
talon peu après son élection en 2016
réclame la restitution de tous les biens
pillés ou daomé par les troupes
coloniales françaises refus catégorique
de l'ancien président françois hollande
au nom du principe d'inaliénabilité du
domaine public c'est le changement à la
tête de l'exécutif français qui fait
bouger les lignes lors de sa tournée à
ouagadougou en novembre 2017 emmanuel
macron créé la surprise je veux ici cinq
ans les conditions sont réunies pour
du bâtiment
quand emmanuel macron reçoit le
président du bénin en mars 2008 son
homologue français évoque encore des
prêts issus des collections françaises
et une coopération muséale il faudra
attendre le rapport des universitaires
sénégalais française bénédicte savoy et
fil wind ça pour que le chef de l'état
français prenne la décision de rendre 26
oeuvres appartenant au bénin après un
feuilleton de plusieurs mois sur fond de
bataille politique
le parlement français approuvent la
restitution des objets culturels du
bénin le 18 décembre 2020 c'est avec
beaucoup d'éclat que l'art classique du
bénin est exposé pour la dernière fois
au musée du quai branly avant la
signature du transfert de propriété
entre les ministres de la culture
français et béninois à la veille du
départ emmanuel macron et patrice talon
entérine la restitution des 26 oeuvres
des trésors royaux d'abomey
très bientôt puisque vous avez
instruit des travaux législatifs vous
définit un cadre plus général de
restituer par ce fait là
le reste
connaîtra le même sort le lendemain et
après presque cent trente ans d'exil
forcé les trésors royaux du bénin font
un retour triomphal sur leur terre
natale c'est la troisième plus
importante restitution d'objets un pays
hors de sang le retour des oeuvres au
bénin c'est aussi vous le savez quelque
chose de très important pour le pays
écoutez le ministre jean michel abimbola
ministre du tourisme de la culture et
des arts au bénin qui s'expriment sur ce
que signifie cette exposition pour le
pays mais aussi pour le continent
africain au micro justement de marie mam
est là
aujourd'hui nous donnons au monde la
possibilité de constater que le bénin et
l'afrique à relever ce défi et nous
voulions dire ici au milieu des oeuvres
les plus emblématiques les trônes de nos
rois les portes du palais les your
statut anthropomorphes et d'autre c'est
une immense émotion c'est une immense
fierté et je voudrais ici dire à toute
la jeunesse africaine
qu'il est désormais temps de nous
réapproprier notre culture il est temps
de connaître notre histoire il est temps
de valoriser notre patrimoine le débat
qui est un un débat d'un autre temps sur
le fait de savoir si l'afrique est
capable de conserver ses oeuvres je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est un débat
éculé et c'est même presque absurde de
poser cette question c'est pour ça que
je vous ne la poserai pas mais je
préfère vous poser la question sur le
futur puisque là on parle du présent le
futur c'est à dire tous les projets et
dieu sait qu'il y en a pour accueillir
d'autres oeuvres et pour mettre en avant
cette culture et se perd patrimoine
béninois nous sommes persuadés que nous
allons créer une industrie
culturelle et créative nous sommes
persuadés que nous allons permettre aux
béninois de s'enrichir d'avoir de
l'emploi d'avoit du bien-être d'être
fiers d'eux mêmes et nous allons
permettre de notre pays de se révéler à
lui-même et de se révéler au monde les
projets sont nombreux et le gouvernement
du bénin sur les cinq prochaines années
va investir la bagatelle
d'un peu plus d'un milliard d'euros je
dis bien près de 700 milliards de francs
cfa rien que dans les projets culturels
artistiques patrimoniaux et touristiques
ce que ça ce sont les projets mais aussi
les ambitions du pays et parmi ses
ambitions c'est pourquoi pas vous l'avez
dit le louvre ici à cotonou une antenne
du louvre à cotonou oui c'est vrai c'est
s'était dit en forme de boutade mais je
peux vous assurer que j'y crois et c'est
surtout pour pouvoir illustrer
l'ambition qui est la nôtre si à horizon
cinq dix ans nous pouvons rêver d'avoir
un livre cotonou c'est que nous aurions
réussi le pari de montrer que le bénin
est une plateforme mondiale de la
culture et que nous avons atteint un
niveau des grands pays pour les
politique muséale pour le le le
dynamisme que nous voulons implémenté de
mise en valeur de la richesse à travers
évidemment le l'éducation de la jeunesse
à travers
l'accès à ces musées à travers les
échanges avec le monde à travers la
circulation de nos oeuvres nous avons
nos oeuvres aujourd'hui restituer mais
ces oeuvres demain peuvent de nouveau se
retrouver en france à londres aux états
unis en afrique du sud au maroc nous
voulons montrer effectivement le
dynamisme de notre pays faire également
la lumière sur notre histoire pour que
le monde puisse se rendre compte que ça
fait longtemps que nous sommes dans
l'histoire elle est comme promis on
retrouve en direct depuis cotonou meriem
amellal qui justement est au palais de
la marina à quelques heures de
l'ouverture de l'exposition meriem
oui on a la chance d'être ici au milieu
de ses oeuvres restituer il n'y a pas si
longtemps par la france c'est une grande
émotion surtout après avoir vu ces
objets et ses oeuvres d'art
c'est au musée du quai branly à paris
les retrouver ici sur leur terre
d'origine c'est beaucoup d'émotion aussi
pour les béninois c'est un événement
très fort les béninois qui disent que ce
n'est pas que ce ne sont pas que des
objets qu'ils ont retrouvé c'est aussi
leur dignité leur fierté c'est une
reconnexion avec leur histoire c'est une
volonté aussi de montrer que le passé
était très fort mais on ne parle pas que
du passé ici on parle aussi du présent
puisqu'il ya une exposition aussi d'art
contemporain une exposition importante
34 artistes vont exposer leurs oeuvres
ici au palais de la marina c'est une
façon aussi de montrer que l'artiste est
au coeur de la société béninoise un peu
comme à l'époque du royaume d'abomey où
l'artiste était le joyau de la cour le
roi lui donner tous les moyens pour
mettre en avant ses oeuvres les
autorités béninoises souhaite aussi
montrer qu'il n'y a pas eu de rupture
avec le passé même si ces oeuvres elles
sont restées sans 29 ans en dehors du
pays eh bien il ya une continuité
l'artiste est toujours au coeur de cette
société ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est que ces artistes contemporains ont
leur place aujourd'hui qu'ils sont que
que la place que le marché de l'art les
reconnaît et qu'aujourd'hui les béninois
vont pouvoir en venant découvrir ses
oeuvres qui sont si attendu découvrir
ces c'est ses oeuvres contemporaines
pour en parler avec moi
léa ou nous qui est directrice générale
de la galerie nationale merci d'être
avec nous alors quelle place aura ces
artistes contemporains dans cette
exposition qui s'intitule je tiens à le
dire art du bénin d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui de la restitution à la
révélation pour compléter merci alors
effectivement cette exposition comme
vous l'avez très justement dit c'est de
montrer la
les talons artistique d'antan et
d'aujourd'hui est donc cette exposition
qui se veut diptyque nous présente l'art
patrimoniale et l'art contemporain et
l'art contemporain que nous avons
présentés sur un espace de 1500 mètres
carrés pour 35 artistes 106,9 montre la
volonté que nous avons de mettre à
l'honneur nos artistes plasticiens la
création et la richesse
artistique contemporaine du bénin donc
c'est vraiment un dispositif qui permet
de montrer ce qu'est le bénin
d'aujourd'hui à travers cette continuité
ce fil entre les artistes d'antan et les
artistes d'aujourd'hui et montrer au
monde notre richesse créative et que le
bénin a sa place dans tout cet univers
artistique cet écosystème artistique
alors ses oeuvres là vous pouvait être
découvertes par par de nombreux béninois
et notamment peut être des enfants nous
sommes nous sommes allés à la rencontre
de ses enfants dans une école à cotonou
pour voir comment ils perçoivent ces
restitutions ce patrimoine de leurs
ancêtres regardez nous sommes à l'école
primaire de quel jeu ou à cotonou le
directeur de l'établissement a bien
voulu nous ouvrir ses portes pour que
nous puissions nous entretenir avec un
professeur et ses élèves de cm2 nous
comptons leur demander comment ils
appréhendent cette restitution d'oeuvres
d'art et comment comptent ils se
réapproprier le patrimoine béninois et
l'histoire de leur pays allons-y bonjour
les enfants
j'aimerais savoir comment vous parlez à
vos élèves de la restitution des oeuvres
d'art au bénin comment vous appréhendez
la question à travers vos cours oui nous
parlons de cette restitution des trésors
allô allô aux élèves à part une bannière
où b on déroule ce cancer de travail
bien pas une leçon de la création des z
les esprits commençaient trésorerie
hausse modérée et comment réagissent-ils
est-ce qu'ils comprennent ce que ça
signifie cette restitution oui
effectivement les enfants ont pu
appréhender quelques notions des trésors
allez je vous laisse alors les
interroger leur poser des questions pour
voir comment ils réagissent
alors que la france a
la france a restitué au paint étaient
six prix d'or royaux
novembre 2001
quel est l'événement majeur que l'on
voudrait pas dans ce cas l'état veut s
pour des traits d'un royaume et les plus
connues puisque
[Musique]
est ce que tu vas y aller à cette
exposition au palais de la marina oui je
vais y aller qu'est-ce que tu imagines
que tu vas trouver sur place j'imagine
que je vais à trouver la trade à émettre
1,7 hors restitués
pour l'instant ces objets sont très
abstrait pour ses enfants mais bientôt
un grand nombre d'entre eux pourront se
rendre sur place visité à cette
exposition à titre gratuit bien
évidemment c'est un projet de
l'éducation nationale ici au bénin merci
beaucoup les ahounou nous avoir
accueillis dans cet endroit magnifique
je rappelle juste que l'exposition ouvre
ses portes ce dimanche eq c'est gratuit
merci merci meriem amellal merci célia
karacena pour cette page spéciale en
direct depuis cotonou l'on remercie tous
nos spectateurs restés avec nous
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]